like I feel like when people take I got
Jack to believe in God wait what yeah
Oh I thought you meant someone was
robbing you while you were believing in
God like like okay
really yeah what happened he's I just
kept talking to him while we were on the
tour bus and I was just like bro all
this just doesn't happen like it's
pretty much what I just preached just
now like I was just like bro this is
you have to believe that this is has to
have somebody when do you think it
clicked for him
I don't think he ever did he didn't tell
me it did but I know it
that's one of those things he didn't
tell me
but in all honesty yeah nah I I mean if
I called him right now I should
he should believe you might have told
the story before but like how did you
and Jack link up and like do some DMS
man really yeah yeah back though before
either of them was doing anything right
yeah you guys you said you had like a
couple hundred followers something like
that yeah we both had a couple thousands
okay yeah we both had a couple thousands
we're just fans of each other's work and
then that should just happen you know
what I'm saying that's so [ __ ] cool
to build and because we talked about
this once you get as big as you are it's
probably hard to trust new people you're
speaking on like my with my weight no no
I believe you've always been this big in
size but Fame
[Laughter]
I see you in all these videos you
penetrate like pop culture in a way
that's [ __ ] amazing gigantic
following yeah whoa dude wow
that was it's almost like you it's
almost like you turned on him that was
your brother
my brother out like give a compliments
oh no that's oh that's your brother's
brother you know oh I see my wow you
trusted him you see what happened that
happened to Jesus
but it's so cool because Mark we got
them all fighting
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
when it's done
all right but for real though how do you
trust new people at this point oh [ __ ]
yeah
that was a long point to me
first yeah
um
you really don't though bro I think he
can also say the same [ __ ] like you kind
of it's like you gotta always have your
guard up for real for like the people
around you you definitely trust you know
what I'm saying and your team and all
that but you really don't trust
everybody like you kind of know what
certain [ __ ] is For What and like this
take this for this you know what I'm
saying like if it's a business
relationship you know that this is
business yeah expect business yeah it's
a friendship expect friendship maybe a
little bit of begging for some money
involved
because you have money you know I'm
saying this friendship's not for no
[ __ ] reason or for cloud reasons you
know what I'm saying like you just
always got to keep your guard up a
little bit you know so you'll never know
sometimes I feel like you build with the
people who who don't want anything yeah
yeah that's the easiest time to do it
like there'll be people who just kind of
offer that's the other thing they're
like sometimes like very successful
people
are the easiest ones to connect with
because they don't need anything from
you from you so is you know for a fact
that there's nothing you could do for
Jay-Z or something like maybe you could
help them with Brands Etc but like okay
they'll be okay yeah you know okay right
so when they're reaching out to you
you know that that's genuine yeah right
they're not going okay how can I get
some a trip to Colorado
[Laughter]
but
[Music]